they see your vulnerability and twisted
in a way that
Twisted in a way that you don't always
expect Jenna Ortega getting emotional
over fame and social media it's just
like a
it's so so strange sorry I don't mean to
do this I don't know I didn't even feel
like I was gonna do this but it is like
it's like such a hard thing to balance
because it's how do you be honest
without
um jeopardizing your own health and and
safety so it's been a bit of an
adjustment the Wednesday actress opens
up about those adjustments while talking
with Elle Fanning for varieties actors
on actors the more
uh I guess I've I've been exposed to the
world in a sense I people pray on that
and take advantage of that and and they
see your vulnerability and and twist it
in a way that
Twisted in a way that you don't always
expects
it's very easy to feel like almost out
of control of things which is why it's
so important I think for people to
get off the phone I don't have a phone I
refuse to be a slave to technology
looks like Jen is taking a page from her
role as Wednesday Adams
I find social media to be a soul-sucking
void of meaningless affirmation
is spilled on what fans can expect for
season two I think that we're kind of
ditching any romantic love interest for
Wednesday which is really great I'm not
interested in participating in tribal
adolescent cliches yep after her
character got tangled in a love triangle
with Tyler Xavier Jen is looking to
focus on other storylines we've had a
lot of conversations and I think we've
decided things that we definitely
um want to enhance or dive a little bit
deeper in I think we want to lean into
the horror aspect of the show a little
bit more because it is so light-hearted
and I think show like this um you know
with vampires and werewolves and yeah
superpowers you just you don't want to
take yourself too seriously which Echoes
what you told E.T last year what do you
hope to explore in a possible second
season I kind of want her to be darker
okay I want her to get more in the
nitty-gritty of things and not play
things so safe because there's a lot of
lines this one about her ah it's just
saving the school and doing whatever I
think I wanted to I want to continue
down an anti-hero stream rather than and
typical year
she also teases resurrecting a character
from the dead oh my God I would die to
work with Gwendolyn Christie for the
rest of my life I know she's perfect so
I'm doing everything in my power to
throw out the most insane plots that
would possibly bring this woman back
from the dead yes I am trying new
premiere date has been announced yet for
season two so while fans wait to scream
it I mean scream it it wouldn't be pure
torture to prep by re-watching season
one you guys are making me nauseous
not in a good way